I was anticipated summer comedies new
Baywatch movie which is a sore subject
for Ken and Steve who are both beat out
for the lead by some guy named Wayne but
we figured it was the right time to play
peach edition of road choads
our popular segment that we should
probably think of a new name for at some
point we're going to show you how
perplexing beach- signposts on one of
the Internet's many fine galleries in
most cases these signs could use a
little more info so for 250 points are
looking to give me a caption to clear
things up first up this confusing
warning Drey warning Noah's Ark crash
site ahead yes fine we're good jinx
warning your hippos and alligators are
useless against flying shark fine ten
are warning hotdogs ingredients ahead
yeah
[Applause]
yeah yep
dick sand sand be careful beware
please notes and one caption goes here
Steve Agee
warning wandering Jew's it's a reference
to the by bad guys yeah guy the Bible 40
years next up if you see someone
drowning whoa
lol what caption here 10 be sure to
administer CPR
OTF lmao f5 very good today also sharks
bt-dubs yeah boy Steve Agee
if you see someone drowning throw one of
your Dalmatians what 101 oh my job odd G
big run